The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to talk a
little bit about producing
and realizing your
visions, and give
an example of some of the things
that Chris was talking about.
So we shot a video on how
engines worked, and there
is a part of the video where
the two creators were talking
about how a turbine
engine works.
And I think I might have
told this story before,
about how we ended up finding
like an actual Boeing engine.
But there are a
lot of ways that we
could have filmed this scene.
We could have animated it, we
could have done a wide frame
shot with animation overlay,
like I showed you with George's
[INAUDIBLE] videos.
We could have done B-roll,
so we could have just done
like close up
shots of the engine
while you heard Luke
explaining how it worked,
with his voiceover.
Or we could have done
a live explanation,
which is what we went with.
So this is how George shot Luke.
We went with the
traditional thirds framing.
Again, this isn't necessarily
a rule that you have to go by,
it just worked really
well for this scene.
And we went with
this because it also
gave us the ability to do sort
of an interesting point of view
shot.
The point of view isn't
from the narrator,
it's actually from the viewer.
So I'll show you the
clip in a second.
But essentially, we
did one long take
where George moved his
camera as Luke was explaining
the parts of the engine.
So we wanted it to feel like
the camera was basically
where a person would be if Luke
was explaining how a turbine
engine works to a
person standing there.
LUKE: --won't work.
FEMALE IN VIDEO:
What you really need
is one engine that can
produce enough horsepower
to fly the plane.
A turbine engine is capable
of much more horse power
than a piston engine
because of the way
it uses giant fans
to compress the air.
LUKE: At the front
of the turbine
engine is an intake
fan which spins
and brings a huge amount of air
into the front of the engine.
As we move backwards
through the engine,
a series of compressor blades
makes that air more and more
compressed, until we get here.
And here, fuel is
introduced and burned.
And that hot, high
pressure flow gets sent
out the back of the engine.
And that makes the
thrust of the engine.
But at the same time,
that flow passes
through a series of four
or five turbine blades,
and those blades are
connected directly
to a shaft at the
middle of the engine.
That shaft runs all the
way back to the front
and spins the intake fan.
That's what keeps
the engine running.
PROFESSOR: So that shot
worked because Luke
was very comfortable explaining
that in one long take.
He actually ad libbed
that whole thing.
And I can see that it's a
lot of information at once,
so maybe it would have been
better to do an animation.
We certainly could've done
it a lot of different ways.
But what I like
about that shot is
that if you were
just standing there,
and Luke was
explaining it to you,
the camera would basically
be your eyes, right?
Like you would walk
along with him,
and you would look down at the
engine when he pointed to it,
you would look back up at him.
So that's the type of movement
that Chris was talking about
that you can introduce
to your video.
It would be really different
if we had just set up a tripod
and had Luke explain
the whole thing, right?
Like it would have been a
very different experience.
GUEST SPEAKER: And it's
not random movement,
it's obviously very
directed, which
is the key to many of
these kinds of things.
It's not [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
Like we wanted to really follow
what the natural person would
do if they were just standing
there talking to Luke.
I want to talk about
the lighting real quick.
So we were in an
airplane hangar,
and it was like
one in the morning,
so it was super dark outside.
I mean, we mostly relied
on the overhead lights.
I don't actually know if we
lit this with anything else.
Because it's super
bright in there.
So you don't need
super fancy equipment
to achieve the videos that
you guys are going to do.
So to talk a little bit
more about producing,
when you think of
directing I feel
like that's what most people
think of when making a video.
And directing is a lot about
thinking in the present.
So you're coaching the host,
you're coaching the talent,
telling them what to do
right there in that moment.
You're thinking about
what the framing looks
like in that moment.
Producing is a lot about
thinking about the future,
anticipating what's coming
next, the mistakes that you're
going to make.
So on a practical level it's a
lot of check boxes, basically.
You're thinking about
where am I going
to film, what are my backups
going to be, where am I
going to record voice over?
My experience filming at MIT is
that it is incredibly difficult
to find a quiet place on campus
to record clean voiceover.
And if you're having
trouble finding a spot,
come talk to me at any time.
I can help you with that.
AUDIENCE: What do you mean that?
Why do you mean that?
PROFESSOR: So take this
classroom for example,
most of the spaces on campus
have this hum overhead.
And most of you guys will be
relying on the lavalier mic,
so it's not as bad.
But there's just a lot
of background noise
that is on campus.
So if you're just
recording plain voice over
that you want to
use in your video,
it would be more
ideal if you could
get something that's quieter
than this room, for example.
So you're thinking
in checklists,
and some of the boxes
are a little more inane,
like did we shoot
all of the scenes?
Which sounds stupid,
but I actually
missed that on my own video.
I forgot to film
one of the scenes.
And then, did we
get clean audio?
So a tip that I would
recommend for you guys
is, even after you film
all of your scenes,
I would sit down and just record
voiceover of your entire script
in a separate audio file.
Because you never know,
looking back on the footage,
there may be sections where
the audio isn't very clean.
So you may have to rely
on your clean voiceover
for that section.
And maybe use B-roll to fill in.
If that makes sense to people.
Does anyone have
questions so far?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Like you are filming,
and then you have a voice--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --then you want to
use a voiceover separately.
Then wouldn't the pacing off?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So for example we shot a
video, and part of it--
I'll talk more about it during
the editing lecture next week,
but if you can find a
clean place to transition
between the live footage
and your voiceover,
that's like the best
way to do that if you
find that some of your footage
just has really bad live audio.
For every place
that you shoot, I
recommend that you get room
tone, which is basically
the natural sound of the room.
So for example, if you were
going to shoot in this room,
you would shoot the scene, and
then you would take your mic
and just record 30 seconds
where everyone's quiet.
And it's just going to
record the background
noise of the room.
And you do that because if
there is a case where you're
relying on voiceover
that you shot later,
or you're cutting bits and
pieces from the footage
that you shot in
this room, you're
going to have this
gap or a hiccup
where the hum doesn't
exist, and it's
going to sound really
awkward in the video.
So you layer the room
tone underneath when
you're editing so that you
don't have those hiccups
between the cuts that you make.
GUEST SPEAKER: It's
kind of a decision
that you have to make,
too, based on the room.
So like with Jeff, we actually
did the voiceover in the room.
Because it had a hum,
so we could have done
a better job of the voiceover.
But what we decided was that it
would be more jarring if there
was a major audio quality
difference between the voice
over and the on
camera, you know,
had we done it in a studio
or in a better space later.
So, you know, it was clean
enough, we accepted it.
And that's why we
had him do everything
on the spot in the same
place, so that it wouldn't
have that drop in and out.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Does that make sense to people?
Like if we took the footage,
like this footage where
I'm talking here, and then
we cut to something where
I continue to talk
about this class,
but I was doing it
over a voiceover,
and we had some B-roll
of you guys working.
The first scene, you
would hear the hum,
and you'd hear me talking.
But in the second
scene, you would just
hear like very clean dead
space while I'm talking.
And you would see
you guys working.
And it would sound
and look really weird.
It would feel really
weird to watch.
GUEST SPEAKER: So we
just did another video
not unlike the
[INAUDIBLE] video,
except that the person is
in Kendall Square talking.
All the on camera stuff
was in Kendall Square.
And that's really
noisy, so we decided in
that case to do the opposite.
We didn't have him record
everything in Kendall Square,
because then we would be dealing
with problems throughout.
But what we did is we recorded
the equivalent of room tone.
We just got audio
of Kendall Square,
and then we were able to
sort of slowly fade it out
after the person was
on camera, so that it
was more imperceptible.
And then slowly fade it
back in before an on camera
arrived-- you know, comes back.
AUDIENCE: There's no way
you can filter it out?
Just kind of--
GUEST SPEAKER: Well
you can filter audio.
What I always tell
people is don't.
Especially like,
if you're not going
to spend thousands
of dollars doing it,
don't think you can do a lot.
There are a lot of consumer
tools that are available.
They generally really
degrade the voice.
Everyone ends up sounding
like I'm Stephen Hawking.
PROFESSOR: Because the
frequencies in the room tone--
GUEST SPEAKER:
Very similar, yeah.
PROFESSOR: --some of the
frequencies in the voice.
GUEST SPEAKER: So very,
very high end, very time
consuming tools are
out there to do it.
But they're out of reach.
PROFESSOR: Music can help
hide that a little bit,
and I'm going to show you guys
examples of that next week.
But in general like it literally
takes 30 seconds for you
to record the room tone.
So that's--
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah,
it's definitely worth it.
PROFESSOR: --It's worth it.
So in general, as
a producer you're
doing a lot of anticipatory
thinking, which
is to help you
ultimately realize
your big vision for your video.
So you're doing all
of these checklists,
you're thinking ahead of time.
Even in pre-production, which
is where we are right now,
where you're scripting.
As a producer you're going to be
thinking about the big picture
the entire time.
So producing is really
looking at the big picture.
You're looking at how the
microscopic decisions like,
where you're going to
shoot for instance,
or where are you going
to record the room tone,
how that all fits into
your macroscopic plan.
So as Chris said, it's really
important to scout locations.
And when you go scout locations,
the two big things to look at
are what's the lighting
like at that place,
and what's the sound like?
And when you're
looking at lighting,
not only look at
the natural light
that's available in the room,
if it's indoors for example,
but how the sunlight
affects the room.
So when we were pre-producing
this OpenCourseWare class,
we came and scouted
this classroom.
And we noticed that there
are all these big windows,
and it was an afternoon class.
And I knew that the
lighting in this room
would be really
different at 1 o'clock
than it would be at 4 o'clock.
So we decided that it actually
wouldn't be too big of a deal,
because people
watching the video
wouldn't be like, oh my gosh
it's dark in that classroom
now, that doesn't
make any sense.
Because obviously we know
it's a three hour class.
GUEST SPEAKER:
You'll notice Billy's
on that side of the room,
not on this side of the room.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER: That's
because if Elizabeth
was teaching in
that corner, we'd
have a problem with the windows.
PROFESSOR: And we thought
about if we should just
lower the shades the entire time
so we have uniform lighting.
So those are the
kind of questions
that you'll ask yourself
during pre-production.
And sound, again,
take room tone.
The biggest sound issues
if you're outdoors,
the wind makes a big difference.
Most of you guys are going to
just rely on your lavaliers,
and they have the little cap.
And that does a
generally good job,
but just take note of
it when you go scout.
My personal tip is
look for outlets.
That's always been
like the biggest thing
for us is, especially if it's
an outdoor location, scouting
ahead of time and seeing
how many outlets there are
helps you anticipate
how many extension
cords you need to bring.
Which sounds like a silly
thing, but actually makes
a huge difference.
So for example we
shot this video
with Jamie in the Stata
Center on computer switches.
And we were with the Digi-Comp.
Or the Digi-Cart?
Digi-Comp.
Which we couldn't move, so we
had to shoot in this location.
And it was in Stata so we
knew it would be really noisy.
So we shot at like 6:00
in the morning on Sunday,
when no one would be around.
But the thing that
we didn't anticipate,
because I didn't scout that
location, which is bad,
is that there's a skylight right
above the Digi-Comp-- I always
forget what it's called.
So noon hit, and we had to
stop filming because there
was sunlight directly
overhead that
completely changed the shadows
on the prop, and on Jamie.
So we basically lost two
hours of shooting time
because we were waiting for
the sun to pass overhead.
So that's why you should scout
your locations ahead of time.
A quick note on locations,
also look at backgrounds.
And with backgrounds you
should really be deliberate.
And go big or go home.
So for example,
this is a background
that I think a lot
of people default
to when they don't really
have anything else to shoot,
because they just sit-in
their office and they're like,
I need to record
something really fast,
I'll just sit here.
Sitting in front of a
window that has blinds on it
is maybe the worst possible
background that you could use.
And again, this is a
matter of personal taste,
but I cringe when I see
this for two reasons.
One, it's really back-lit,
which is what Chris
was talking about earlier.
So you'll have so
much outdoor light
that it makes your
subjects look really dark.
And having all the
blinds in the background,
I think having all those lines
is really distracting as well.
This is what
happened when George
tried to change the exposure
setting on the camera
to light for me.
So I'm lit well, but
now the background
is completely blown out.
So in general, avoid filming
right in front of a window
where there is direct
sunlight coming in.
And please don't film
in front of blinds.
If anyone is
interested in filming
in front of a green
screen, it's possible,
and I'm happy to help you.
I think you should be very
deliberate with that decision.
Sometimes it works really well.
This is an example.
FEMALE IN VIDEO: So
in order to turn red,
neurons from the squid's
brain sends signals
to these muscles, which pull
open all of his chromatophores
at the same time.
PROFESSOR: So-- oh,
this was the wrong clip.
Sorry guys.
But there is one
example where she
says, take note, when I
walk next to the squid,
he turns red.
And so you actually see
her walking on screen,
and then the squid turns red.
And so we used a green
screen to film this
because we like
the actual visual
of seeing some sort of
object stimulating the squid
to turn colors.
So that's an example of a
green screen working well,
I think in my opinion.
If you want to do something like
that, I'm happy to help you.
But again, you
don't have to do it.
So more production tips.
Days before, make sure
you scout your locations.
A word about props.
So props don't have
to be expensive.
And I'm not just talking
about props on screen.
I'm also talking about the
tools that you can use to film.
So we're giving you a
tripod, and that's basically
your only production prop.
But as Chris was saying,
like you can use desk lamps
with paper over them.
Let me show you this shot.
FEMALE IN VIDEO:
Let me show you how.
PROFESSOR: So those are
all dolly shots basically,
of us establishing the
location of this video, which
is in D lab, which
is where Jack works.
And they're all very smooth
pans of looking around
at the locations.
And we shot that with
a cart, like a hand
cart that I just sat in,
and George pushed me around.
So you could buy a
super expensive dolly,
or you can just borrow a
cart from our department,
and sit-in it, and have
someone push you around.
The dolly is always
nicer, but we
don't have the budget for that.
GUEST SPEAKER: Great job with
steady camerawork by the way.
It can be an issue if
you're sitting on a cart,
if you start getting
a lot of this,
it takes away from the
niceness of the shot.
But in this case it was great.
PROFESSOR: We took a
tripod and spread the legs
out all the way, so that
it was like really, really
firm in the cart.
And then I held it just
to add more stability.
So it's possible
this is another one.
FEMALE IN VIDEO: To figure
out how the entire metabolome
works, we can use it
to engineer plants
to create new bio-materials,
medicines, and clean energy.
We might even discover
that plants have
the secret to living forever.
We just need to unlock
their chemical mysteries.
PROFESSOR: So that's actually
one of my favorite shots
from Science Out Loud, ever.
And that was all George's idea,
so I have to give him credit.
But I like it because
it's a reveal,
like Chris was talking about.
It's the way we ended the video.
We start off on the
plants, focused on it,
and you reveal
Anastasia at the end.
And that's actually-- to
get that smooth movement is
actually really hard.
You might be able to do
it with these tripods
because the cameras
aren't really heavy.
And you could probably get
enough friction on them
to get it to work.
But what we did was, George was
using a camera like that one.
So he took the tripod, flipped
the top head of it upside down,
and then he took a boom
pole, which is basically
this long pole, and put a
weight on one end of it,
and put the camera on the
other, and just slowly let
the camera come up
from the weight.
So I'm all about MacGyvering
props if you need to.
There are creative ways to
get around things and achieve
nice effects with
cheaper equipment.
The other thing
about days before
is that you should make a shot
list, which is something that I
would like you guys to submit.
I think originally
I had specified
you to do that tonight.
But it's not necessary to do
it and post it until next week.
So I'll update you
with another email.
But a shot list is
basically what it says.
It's a list of all the
shots that you need.
So it doesn't have to
look a certain way.
It's for your benefit only.
So organize it however
you think is best for you.
But this was my shot
list for the reshoots
that we did for the snots video.
This is the first page of it.
So I listed out
all the locations
that we were going to, what
time approximately we were going
to use it, so that I could
get a good sense of what
the lighting would look
like in these locations.
And then I listed out exactly
what lines I needed to say,
and what shots we needed
to get at each location.
And then at the bottom I
specified the wardrobe.
So this is a super helpful
organizational tool
to use when you're
planning things.
When you are thinking
about locations,
definitely go big or go home.
You can e-mail anyone
and just tell them
you're doing a project
for a class at MIT,
and you'd be surprised
what you could get.
We shot at a horse
farm in Acton.
We shot in an airplane.
We shot at a skydiving zone.
We shot at the butterfly exhibit
at the Museum of Science.
Most of the labs
here, especially
since you're students, are going
to be super open to having you.
And again that's
like your opportunity
to create a window into a
world that most people don't
have access to.
So definitely take
advantage of that.
If you have any issues
getting into a location,
just let me know.
The day before, check
all your equipment.
Check the batteries,
that's the biggest thing.
Bring spare batteries.
If you need spare
batteries let me know.
Double check your locations.
If you're meeting
people, make sure
that they know
that you're coming.
And check the weather.
And then day of.
So to help keep you organized
I recommend that you use
camera reports or log sheets.
And what that looks
like, and again you
can set this up however you
think is most useful to you
to use.
These are the camera
reports that we
use for Science Out Loud.
But basically it's
to help us keep track
of what video file is what.
And when you're shooting
like for six days straight,
this is really important.
It may not be as vital to you,
but it'll be really useful
when you go into edit.
But it's basically saying,
this video file was scene two,
take two.
I thought it was OK.
There were two good
takes in there.
The last one was the best.
Make sense to everyone?
Let me know if you
have any questions.
Yeah.
That's pretty straightforward.
And I would also recommend
looking at the dailies.
So I guess dailies
refers to all the footage
that you take during a day.
Like maybe during a movie
production or a TV production.
And the dailies
for you guys would
be like, at the
end of the day look
through all the video footage
that you have on your camera
and just take note
of what you shot.
Make sure that it's good.
What you don't want is to
shoot your entire episode
and realize that the camera
settings had somehow muted you
and so you didn't
have any audio.
So that's why looking at
the dailies is important.
Also back up and label
all your files like right
after you get back from a shoot.
So the biggest production
piece of advice,
or like heads up that
I would give you guys
is that it takes a lot of time.
Even if the
locations are scouted
and everything's sort of
organized perfectly the day of,
you're going to take-- you're
going to do a lot of takes.
Even if the person says
the line perfectly,
try a bunch of deliveries.
So remember how George
was saying like,
say it really loud!
Now say it like however
you want, right?
And you got a different style.
Try a bunch of deliveries.
Try a different bunch of point
of views with the camera.
So maybe you shoot
someone straight on,
then you try something
from the side.
You try a different movement.
And then like try
different types of framing.
And Chris's piece
of advice, which
was like, most people tend
to not get enough footage
than get too much,
is really true.
Shoot like you're going
to use everything,
and then when you
edit, you're going
to edit it like you're not
going to keep anything.
But when you're
shooting, you always
want to have more to work with,
because the worst feeling is
when you're sitting,
editing, and you're like,
I wish I had shot x y z.
It's the worst feeling.
So it's going to
take a lot of time,
because you want to create
as many options for you
as you can.
Any questions about that?
No?
OK.
So I'll show you
an example of this.
No, one more thing.
A note about clothing, because
sometimes this comes up.
So in general you don't want
to have really fine print.
So I always try
to avoid stripes.
This is probably like
the closest or the widest
difference in your stripes
as I would recommend getting.
Generally like solid colors
work the best on screen.
And then the material,
bring a couple
different sets of shirts
with you, because sometimes
like the silkier material
brushes up against the mic
a little bit more, and you hear
that actually on the audio.
I will show you some raw
footage from the snots video.
This is super
embarrassing for me, so.
But I think it's good.
And maybe will just
sort of set the tone
that this is a safe
space where you can feel
like you can just be yourself.
But this was for
B-roll at the beginning
of the video that
was literally going
to last-- it's going to last
one second in the final product.
I literally mean I think it's
going to be a one second clip.
And this is the amount of
footage we shot for it.
FEMALE IN VIDEO: --little
weight is so funny.
MALE IN VIDEO: OK, thank you.
And go.
Put it down and get
the little weight.
Both hands.
Do the thing where you
like, you're bringing it
up with your right
hand, and then
you're sort of like spotting
it with your left a little bit.
OK.
No, no just two fingers
on the other hand.
On your hand, on your hand,
the back of your hand.
Like
FEMALE IN VIDEO: This?
MALE IN VIDEO: Higher.
Turn the weight more.
Yeah.
Just go like this.
Put-- yes, and then like,
as if you're helping it up.
MALE IN VIDEO 2: [INAUDIBLE]
just like, supporting it.
MALE IN VIDEO: Yeah, like that,
but don't take your face out
of frame.
Slower.
Struggle a little bit more.
All right, good.
PROFESSOR: So the
point of making you
guys endure that is
that the final clip is
going to be just, right?
Literally a second.
This is at least two
minutes worth of footage.
This was like the third take.
So this is what I mean by
get as much as possible.
Try as many different
things as you can.
Because we could have used the
first one where I just like
lifted the weight, but the
last one was really the best
take out of all of them.
And it wasn't-- we
didn't achieve that.
Or we achieved that
because George made
me do it for like 10 minutes.
But don't tell him I said that.
So these are all
the day of things.
Now for the day after,
take a step back for now.
It's going to be hard to go in
and edit your stuff like right
after you finish shooting it.
You want to give yourself
a little bit of time
to sort of clear
your perspective.
And I'll talk more about this
during the editing lecture.
But even when you do
the camera reports
and you're logging sort of what
the best takes are the day of,
you might watch it
a couple days later.
And I recommend re-logging
everything and going
through footage again later.
And you might find that
the thing that you liked
during the day of,
maybe you liked it
because you were
starting to get tired,
and it's going to look a
little bit different later.
So that's why I just
recommend the day after,
just taking a step back.
Let's see.
Oh.
With the whole
multiple takes thing,
I forgot to mention this
before, but I thought of it when
you were doing your lecture.
I would also
recommend doing takes
from varying degrees of
separation from your subject.
So say your host says, I'm
going to say this line,
and you shoot it from
where Chris is standing.
Even if the host like
nails the line perfectly,
tell them to do it again
and shoot it from maybe
from where Yulia's standing.
And tell them to do it again,
and shoot it from like right
here.
It's just good to have those
varying degrees of separation.
It'll be easier to do the
zooming and everything in post.
But again, having those
options to work with.
You're not going to
know which one you're
going to use necessarily in
the moment that you're filming.
So that's why it's good
to have a couple options.
GUEST SPEAKER: The term is--
the technical term, not that it
matters, is called, coverage.
So basically, you
cover yourself.
I don't really know how I'm
going to edit this together,
so I'm going to give
myself as many choices as
possible in the edit room.
Because even the best directors
don't know exactly what
they want.
I mean there's Alfred Hitchcock
supposedly only filmed
exactly what he wanted.
And his editors went insane
because they could only
do one way.
But pretty much
everyone else who's
ever worked at any level in
film and video does coverage.
PROFESSOR: Does
anyone have questions?
The rest of class, we're
going to let you go actually
film a scene from your script.
And maybe this is a good
time to take a break,
but Chris and I
will stick around
if you have questions about
producing your specific scene,
or actually using
any of the equipment,
we'll be around to help
you with that stuff.
AUDIENCE: Can I make one
other suggestion, or just
reinforce one thing
about producing.
This comes up over
and over again,
and it was a very hard lesson
for me to learn initially.
And that's being realistic
about your schedule.
You know there's a tendency to
want to pack a ton of stuff in
and to be very ambitious.
And what happens
is that you have
to give enough time for setting
things up, breaking things
down, moving from
this lab to that lab,
or this location
of that location,
eating something,
figuring something out.
So if you go like, well, OK.
This is a 10 minute scene,
this will take me 20 minutes
to edit.
And then we'll be over at Stata,
and we'll shoot that two minute
scene in five minutes.
You know, very, very
quickly get behind schedule,
and then the panic sets in.
It's far better to have a
schedule that's realistic,
where you really think
about, not just what it's
going to take to
shoot, but what it's
going to take to set up,
breakdown, figure stuff
out, and move.
And then execute the
schedule in a realistic way
so you're not panicking,
you're not freaking out,
you're not calling
people and saying,
I know I said I would
be at your lab at 3:00
but I can't get there till
5:00, can you stick around?
You know, whatever it may be.
So just be very realistic.
PROFESSOR: For the
Science Out Loud episodes,
we allot at least 12 hours
per five minute episode
in terms of filming
time with the students.
Now that's a huge number,
mostly because the thing that's
most time consuming
for us is setting up
the lights, which is
something that you're not
going to have to worry about.
The lighting
actually-- I mean, it's
by far the most time
consuming thing.
But it gives you
an idea of-- that's
a really great point I'm
glad that you made it--
that it's more than
just the amount
of time it takes for
you to say a line.
Hopefully you won't
have that panic,
because the way this
class is structured,
it's very front heavy.
We've had a lot
of lectures so far
but after the editing
lecture, that's
actually the very last one.
And the rest of the
class period will mostly
be for you to work on
stuff during class time.
So don't worry too
much about that.
We tried to anticipate
that for you guys.
But just to let you know.
I forgot had a couple examples
for you for some of the stuff
that Chris was mentioning.
And I'll play them real quick.
MALE IN VIDEO: What is the most
awesome place in the world?
Seems like that would be
pretty much the most subjective
question ever.
But this week, scientists used
a set of objective criteria
to come up with a list of
the world's most biologically
important places.
There might be--
PROFESSOR: So that's an example
of having zooms, but not
actually showing you zooming
with the camera, right?
And I think they do it
for a couple reasons.
He probably-- he might have
messed up his line in between,
and so that was a way to
sort of cut in between
and not make the cuts
like super awkward,
by having a zoom
in and a zoom out.
And it's sort of like a rhythmic
visual pacing thing, too.
It cuts in like after he says--
GUEST SPEAKER: It's kind
of equivalent to, oh,
different angle, pay attention.
It's a different
convention than television,
but it comes from a
very similar place.
You know, if he was
just standing there,
delivering without
edits, there'd
be this-- there's this terror
that you might turn away,
and might not watch it.
PROFESSOR: To
achieve that, though,
if you wanted to do something
like that, I would say,
again, you could even
film this with a tripod
and film yourself.
But I would shoot
yourself-- that sounds
weird-- I would take the camera
and put it on tripod like that
far away, deliver
your whole sentence,
and then move it forward and
deliver the whole thing again.
Because you don't
know exactly where
you're going to cut into that.
GUEST SPEAKER:
And that's clearly
what most people--
I mean, this is
a very conventional thing you
see on the web all the time.
And that's how they film.
You know, a bunch of takes
of wide, a bunch of takes
of close, medium, whatever.
Editing.
PROFESSOR: But the
point is you're
going to be saying the same
line multiple times, even
if you nail it.
This is where a zoom might work.
[VIDEO PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: So I say, or is it.
But we use the zoom there
intentionally to make it funny.
Which hopefully it'll read
funny in the actual thing.
So again, there aren't
like hard and fast rules
were you should never
ever use a zoom,
or you should never
ever center the person,
or you should never ever--
GUEST SPEAKER:
It's interesting, I
mean, you know, I
was thinking about
that whole centering thing
after the other day, Monday.
And a lot of times
when people break
those kind of traditional
rules, is for comedic effect.
And center frame stuff
tends to read funny.
And you see that in
movies all the time.
If you start paying
attention to this.
If you go to a comedy, things
tend to be more center frame
than if it's a drama.
And I think one of the
reasons that vlogs are often
center framed is that,
even if they're not funny,
that's the affect.
It's like this is amusing, this
is light, this is not scary.
And that's why
people center frame.
And you know, you can, too.
If you want to.
PROFESSOR: All right so, at this
point I will let you guys free.
Oh, sorry I have
another thing to say.
The film that
you've seen today--
the scene that you film today
won't be due until at least
Tuesday.
If you need more
time to work on it,
we can push it to
Wednesday, too.
And that's because I
really want your focus
to be on honing the script.
Because Monday will
be our table read,
where everyone reads their
script aloud to each other.
And you're really going
to get the most out
of the table read when you
come to it with as complete
as a script as you can.
I'm not saying that
what you have on Monday
should be as close to
final product as possible,
but it's just really hard
to give concrete feedback
to something that isn't
fully fleshed out.
So do try to come on Monday
with as complete of a script
as you can, because Monday is
going to be the most useful
to you if you do.
So that being said,
some people have already
uploaded second
drafts onto Tumblr.
If you could upload stuff
by tomorrow at noon,
I can give you feedback on it
so that you can incorporate that
before Monday.
And the best way to
get feedback from me
is to double post to Tumblr, and
then also write a Google doc,
and just email it to me, and
give me commenting permissions.
That's how we actually
edit all the scripts
from Science Out Loud.
So I'll show you, real quick.
Season two.
Let's go to this one.
Yeah, so this is eventually
how we asked the students
to format their scripts.
You don't have to
do that for Monday,
but eventually you're
going to want to do it.
I think it makes organizing
things a lot easier.
So it's just like a
four column format,
where you specify what scene
number it is, the location.
So OS just means on screen.
It means like you're
not going to B-roll,
you're just going to
be delivering it live.
Just a description of
what the video looks like,
and what the script is itself.
And if you share it
to me on Google Docs,
it just makes it easier
for me to comment for you.
And George also said that we
will give script feedbacks
this weekend too.
So if you can e-mail us this
stuff by Saturday at noon,
we can give you lots of
feedback before Monday.
AUDIENCE: I have another tip
that I usually forget about
because I'm not used to talking
for long periods of time,
and you guys will probably
get tired at some point
while filming.
Bring a water bottle
and probably snacks too,
if you get hungry easily.
Just because when your
voice gets really dry
and starts cracking, that might
ruin a take that otherwise
went really, really well.
And it helps with the
consistency of your voice.
And you can edit
together something
that you did later with
something that you did earlier
if your voice sounds
like consistently fresh
throughout it.
Because I've had problems
trying to edit audio
where at the end of it, my
voice is really, really raspy.
And at the beginning
it's still good.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's a great point.
I'm glad you brought that up.
So we try to cram
everything in as much
as we can, which is purely
because of logistical issues,
and because of our budget.
But you're going
to have the time
this month to where
you're not going
to have to shoot your
entire video in one day.
So really try to spread
it out over the course
of several days.
And that's built
into the class time.
But I will just say from
personal experience,
it is so incredibly difficult
to film for more than five
or six hours straight.
You just get really, really
exhausted by the end of it.
OK.